loch ness numero due mi per chi ha un
secondo e inizia la giornata vi
appoggiate dai fatti questi letti c'è la
prima goccia e l'alza bandiera quella
non so come fare un letto cartelli no
avete preso né colazione 61 sul tavolo
sono le regine questa dimora di contanti
a molto spacchiamo questo mi ha reso da
chi per giorni faremo un'idea
semplicemente nel mio nome di comparire
considera in sella ma meno la madre che
ci proverà del genere sottili grazie
fatto le vostre vere il faraone ma
questa non sa quanto ce ne messo quindi
cui si parlava che cos'è questo volto
ansiogena ecco che cos'è con il
predatore
e non ci credo cosa sono bagnate questa
carta
già è tutto totalmente pazzi rimasticare
guglielmo sull telefono con l'ospite
segreto voi avete capito piero non ha
idea tu sai che io non lo so così valore
che sei super tirato pare il rehab
importante crederci però il look per la
pisciatina di culto di oggi e ama
libertà ho appena fatto chiacchiera con
una ragazza supergentile che aveva
ancora un bulldog non si è minimamente
curata del mio vestito perché le persone
dovrebbero essere così preoccuparsi
della sostanza di non dell'apparenza
nobilissimo le persone per quello che
fanno e non per come appaiono karimun
multe meno fregature in generale la vita
e la misurazione amore per aver detto
questa cazzata cui si stanno tra persone
come se fosse il povero pazzo ragazzi a
chi c'è serenità
io vado a fare la doccia che faccio
pagare vado al pullman di quanto manca
posso farmi la doccia quando scendi
scendi subito fermato di pietro
ecco marco ipad col pullman massima che
ci ai piedi e ciabatte viso lettere
rispetto al sultano del confronto sono
mister sobrietà che c'è pure l'uncino
ecco qua io vedo spettacolari google e
odia
andare a farmi oggi trepidazione massima
che ho fatto una grande cosa ha comprato
tutto sospeso pochi euro meno di dieci
più di cinque per prendere cosa la
capanna che a parigi manga kabanga lo
useremo per tutte le ricette latte
biscotti al pesce al cartoccio man band
spagnola deve routine africano pazzesco
perché in 20 parole che non esistono
ormai ha messo un agente nacca nei
messaggi banca che ha pagato hanno preso
per il culo aggrava col kh paga ma
carichi di cicala calandra sentire la
utilizzerà il grinding di cucina tutto
lo sai mettere
cavani trasforma i piatti che andando
con capri a fare la spesa non prendiamo
casi troppo pesanti che la cosa migliore
è stato un po legge modo da arrivare col
fisico a natale già visto meyer fisico a
natale come questa roma la turista roba
da turista un'altra storia fai un gesto
della bellezza di roma a servire per i
piccioni romana turista le sue
meraviglie giacca marrone
la bellezza dei turisti vola figlio di
roma con a tratti di una cosa bellissima
romana turista questa voglia mogli
attivo benvenuti al rione monti è stato
a casa mia
sarà il portone abitavo qui che è
successo poi prova quanto ci ha abitato
meno due settimane a londra ma dello
sfratto detto dietro l'angolo sto
attraversando lo abbiamo superato
supermercato chiamo trovare un bar bere
un caffè da turista portato a prendere
il caffè da turista e tu le stai
approfittando per prendere la pizzetta
piccola tonda da turista buonissimo
eccola qui mamma servono mi sento molto
lista e respirando roma adesso che se
uscito di casa ti senti meglio meglio
bene qui venite siccome questa pizza
vissuta da turista r penso che stavate
ritirando adesso vi faccio entrare nel
blocco dei turisti questa mezza da
mangiare questa pizza ma sta respirando
la pizza l'aria di roma milan guarda
dintorni guarda questa prateria sulla
destra bravo si vola pizza e sorridi e
gira introna con la turista non c'è
nulla di meglio di una città come roma
uno scorcio come affittasi un caffè
profumo del turismo lungo dietro
bicchiere che non è mio
tutta una magia del natale fuori da come
si è vestito e cosa mi ricordo un
turista un turista nero e differenza se
per te il loro nessuna star da lei come
si atteggia alta con la sua classe e
l'eleganza il suo cappotto di visone
sottodivisione di turista cartoline da
turista
l'esposizione mediatica cartoline va di
fare cose devo comprare calamite modo
tornare cose bisogna eventi della mia ex
casa scapece avuto due settimane non ho
visto tante cose quanti amici andarsene
tanti ma ora dopo siamo riusciti
supermercato di finn di fiducia di una
cosa verdi nota alcuna cosa a verde
facendo un braccio di ferro infinito o
gocce di cioccolato fondente per mandare
giù lo yogurt preso tutto c'è stato un
imprevisto spesa appena accordo con la
scusa di uno di meno non da dire ti
posso immaginare via mia scelta ma sono
indovinati attrezzo porta ci deve dire
una cosa di banane
le ho comprate io
hanno riconosciuto a parte ma scusa
tematiche preoccupate imprenditori di
banane se rimaniamo vandelli festa di
portare all album presunte io enrico non
azzardare farei autonomia in stand e
cabriolet io faccio il light del 3 pole
per la cosa grazia perché la carta per
ora hanno preso le uova difettose questa
su quelle che funziona non ci hanno pure
il pallino la casa la peste non ce
l'avevano ma non so perché lassative che
la mattina quando gli ebrei si faccia un
bar cake protesi tutti il libro gli
occhioni a cui ci facciamo mandorle che
basta di lenticchie rosse biologica
vi hanno preso parte di topi non so dove
le voglia mettere quelle vanno bene
ovunque precari che atto è sparito e un
buco una volta dentro il frigorifero per
almeno un paio d'ore non c'era un peso
opposto civile infilato da bersi un
bicchiere d'acqua
chi è stato o per esagerare è
nell'inquadratura il colpevole fateci
sapere
mettendo la mano sul cuore chi secondo
lui è stato mai nicolosa su tutti quanti
adesso siete sotto il giudizio degli
spettatori unici
che cos'era gabriele spazzerebbe mai
qualcosa basta
mi dica persona che non c'era qui a
piedi scalzi non ci sono più
no no vattene via corrompe rho il
montata parla della confessione io ho
messo il registratore in tasca al
vicinato ma da fini che è stato e
lavinia ammette
noi mette così sono stato io no del
ministro il paese pesaro del com
non riesco ad uscire da questo lupa che
qui assolutamente aiutare a farlo
fraternizzare con gould ecco qua non se
ne importa niente più solamente di una
cosa quasi gatto di là vignati ma
guardate la salute degli animali belle e
un po di gruppi i suoi ma i miei animali
accontenti quasi sono dei santi ragazzi
degli alloggi finisce qua come sempre
iscrivetevi mettete in pollice in su se
ti stanno facendo questi blog ma
aiutateci a continuare a convivere con
la mente al giorno o due
noi ci vediamo domani con la terza
puntata del blog ma sale 14 e poi
andiamo avanti ad oltranza non bene su
cina e poi chiacchiere a chiacchiere
ciao